and we as reasonable people
should not have to argue what critical
race theory is
it's not a thing we should have to do
and it's a thing that we shouldn't do
when we get into arguments with these
[ __ ] people about critical race
theory they're not talking about actual
critical race theory that's not what
they're talking about
it's clear now more than ever after last
night's election that when they say
critical race theory they don't mean
what it actually means
they're not saying the critical race
theory in law schools right and it does
us no good to have this discussion back
and forth
about something that that that is not
what they're talking about
they're not talking about the legal
critical race theory
what these people and i i've heard it
from people that i know
from the mouths of people that i know
because i live in in trump land
in a red state i know a lot of people
who are trump supporters
fortunately or unfortunately the
fortunate part is i get a deep dive into
what they actually think and what they
say
and how they view the world
and listen up they don't they don't care
that critical race theory actually
derived from germany as a study in law
they don't give a [ __ ]
that's not what they mean by critical
race theory
they they don't they don't think that
that they don't care that that that's
what you think critical race theory is
that's not what they're saying what
they're saying is critical race theory
is this scary thing
that is designed to change education to
make white kids feel guilty and feel bad
for being white that's what critical
race theory is to these people
if you think build a wall
meant
that they were gonna build a wall and it
was gonna keep everyone out even though
we were like there's such things as
airplanes and ladders then you weren't
listening
you weren't listening they don't give a
[ __ ] about ladders and airplanes when
they say build a wall they don't care
about truth they don't care about what
actual words mean
they only care about what words mean to
them
it's their it's their privilege to
change the meaning of words and to
change the truth it's their privilege
jesus christ did you watch all the white
people down in dallas
thinking that john f kennedy jr was
going to come back and run with trump
yesterday